[Music]
you're swimming in the ocean when
something brushes your leg when the
tingling sets in you realize you've been
stung by a jellyfish how do these
beautiful gelatinous creatures pack such
a painful punch jellyfish are soft
because they are 95% water and are
mostly made of a translucent gel-like
substance called messag Lea with such
delicate bodies they rely on thousands
of venom containing stinging cells
called cnidocytes for protection and
prey capture even baby jellyfish the
size of a pencil eraser have the ability
to sting larval jellyfish every look
like tiny flowers pulsating in the sea
as they grow they become umbrella-shaped
with the bell at the top and descending
tentacles around the margin the largest
species of jellyfish the lion's mane has
tentacles that can extend more than 100
feet longer than a blue whale these
tentacles contain most of the stinging
cells although some species have them on
their bells too venom is ejected via
animat assists a whip like hollow tube
you'll which lies coiled under high
osmotic pressure when mechanical or
chemical stimuli activate an external
trigger the lid of the cell pops open
and seawater rushes in this forces a
microscopic barbed harpoon to shoot out
penetrate and inject venom into its
victim
nomads assist discharge can occur in
less than a millionth of a second making
it one of nature's fastest biomechanical
processes
Nomad assists can continue to fire even
after a jellyfish has died so it's
important to remove lingering tentacles
stuck to the skin rinsing with vinegar
will usually render undischarged Nomad
assists inactive seawater can also help
remove residual Nomad assists but don't
use fresh water because any change in
salt balance alters the osmotic pressure
outside of the Naito site and will
trigger the Nomad assist to fire
that's why urinating on the affected
area a common folk remedy may do more
harm than good depending on the
composition of the urine most jellyfish
stings are a painful nuisance but some
can be deadly an indo-pacific box jelly
also called a sea wasp releases venom
which can cause contraction of the heart
muscles and rapid death in large doses
there's an anti-venom but the venom is
fast-acting
so you'd need immediate medical
intervention
despite the impressive power in their
tentacles jellies aren't invincible
they're stinging cells are no match for
the armor of thick skin predators like
the leatherback turtle and ocean sunfish
these predators both have adaptations
that prevent slippery jellyfish from
escaping after they are engulfed
backwards pointing spines in the turtles
mouth and esophagus and recurved teeth
behind the son fish's cheeks even tiny
slipper lobster larvae can cling to the
bell of a jellyfish and hitch a ride
snacking on the jelly while they
preserve their own energy for growth
small agile fish use the jellies as
moving reefs for protection darting
between tentacles without ever touching
them nudibranch s' which our sea slugs
covered in protective slime can actually
steal the jellies defenses by eating the
cnidocytes
and transferring them to specialized
sacks for later use as weapons against
their own predators even humans might
benefit from the sting of a jellyfish
one day scientists are working on
manipulating cnidocytes to deliver
medicine with no mat assists rarely
three percent of the size of a typical
syringe needle so the next time you're
out in the ocean be careful but also
take a second to marvel at its wonders
you
[Music]